Hey, this is just unbelievable.
The pro Trump election fraud lawyer Lin Wood
is under investigation for possibly voting
illegally himself.
This is being reported by WSB TV in Atlanta.
Lin Wood, a lawyer, filed lawsuits to try
to steal the election for Trump, held rallies
to try to steal the election for Trump, claimed
people voted illegally in the twenty twenty
presidential election.
And WSB TV in Atlanta, Georgia, can now report
that the state is investigating Lin Wood for
potentially having voted illegally in the
state of Georgia.
Reporter Justin Gray was able to confirm yesterday
that the Georgia secretary of state is looking
into whether Lin Wood was even eligible to
vote in the state of Georgia and whether he
actually broke the.
For when he voted and potentially wrongly
claimed to be a Georgia resident, Linwood
said it's 1776 in America and we're not going
to let them take our freedom, that freedom
being that he claimed Trump was the rightful
winner of the election and people voted illegally
for Joe Biden or the numbers were messed with
or the machines were messed with or whatever.
But he himself, he himself, Lin Wood, may
have voted illegally, of course, for Donald
Trump in the state of Georgia.
The incredible detail here is that sources
at the Georgia secretary of state's office
say the reason they're even investigating
Lin Wood is that Lin Wood emailed their office
and said, I moved to South Carolina.
He admitted to them, quote, I have been domiciled
in South Carolina for several months after
purchasing property in the state in April.
Presumably the reason Lin Wood was telling
this to the Georgia secretary of state was
related to taxes.
You want to when you change states.
I don't I don't even know the tax rates in
Georgia and in South Carolina.
But very often when you change states and
you go to a lower tax state, or at least you
want to avoid having to file taxes in two
states, even if the tax rates are similar,
you want to make sure that the state you've
left knows you have severed your relationship
with them.
When people move from New York to Florida,
this is a whole legal and accounting thing
where how do you demonstrate you really are
no longer responsible for any taxes in New
York?
So Lin Wood said, I'm domiciled in South Carolina,
presumably for tax purposes.
And as a result of that, the secretary of
state in Georgia is now looking at whether
he even should have been legally allowed to
vote in Georgia in November.
So this is all, yeah, maybe Lin Wood was right
after all, and people did vote illegally and
he meant himself.
Maybe he really did have that personal knowledge
because it was he himself who actually did
it.
And while they're at it, check Trump's voting
as well.
Moving from New York to Florida, voting by
mail.
It's all very, very suspicious, right?
Endless projection from these people.
It never, ever, ever ends.
And there is no there is no hypocrisy, too
great.
There is no instance of Protech of projection
that goes beyond what these people are capable
of.
And we've talked before about how for all
the talk about voter fraud, the people getting
caught are either Republicans doing it or
Republicans trying to, quote, test the system
to show how easy it is to do.
And it turns out it's not actually that easy
because they keep getting caught, will follow
the investigation into Lin Wood and whether
he did or didn't vote illegally.
But it is it's is it fair to call it a comedy
of errors?
I don't know that these are really errors.
These really do seem like fraudsters.
Maybe we need a different term for it.
We'll have more on this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page.
Make sure you're following us at The David
Pakman Show on Instagram.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman, The David Pakman Show at
David Pakman Dotcom.